oui je voulais je voulais vous d'abord
vu ce que tu es une très très belle
année bon ça commence très mal c'est
vrai un pas très bien pas terrible même
mais sont peut-être que nous finirons
très fin sur la fin
[Musique]
bien aussi je voulais vous dire je vous
dis vous dire aussi merci parce que j'ai
été très secouée par une certaine presse
qui annonçait la disparition
assez récente
ça m'a évidemment beaucoup frappé et
j'ai eu des milliers de des milliers de
messages
mais pour me dire toute leur affection
et et m'encourager devants dans cette
épreuve que j'ai traversés ben je suis
toujours là en pleine forme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]